hey Adam thank you for being here this  is awesome to have you here  Tim recover it's gonna be great Jim more  yeahh two more yeahh  I'm driver yeah it's so good to see you  in person  it's I've just been looking at you  online for years not only my big fan of  yours I'm a big fan of men's fashion in  general the whole canvas tote bag with a  leather trim wow that's awesome what are  you worried no I just  don't worry everything about you is this  Lacoste did you know hold on how did you  know that the cost was the first friend  to put logos on their shoes  Yoji 511 yeah they are I don't do you  mind if I wear them well we've got oh  we've got a lot I think actually you  know what I'm getting a phone call here  I'm gonna I'll be right back we'll  continue this I'm gonna show you my gym  [ __ ] more shirt  you  [Music]